bien joué défendre en touchant son
adversaire et lui laisser deux secondes
pour faire une passe c'est la nouvelle
règle mise en place dans les écoles de
rugby et notamment ici au rugby-club de
versailles une disposition en oeuvre
depuis quatre ans en ile-de-france pour
favoriser un style de jeu et sécuriser
les joueurs
le but c'est d'inciter par la règle à
faire évoluer le jeu donc c'est du rugby
à toucher donc avec continuité du jeu
touché deux secondes touché avec ballons
donnés au contact
aujourd'hui c'est repris par la
fédération française au niveau des
écoles de rugby et aujourd'hui ce qui se
rajoutent ont plus effectivement c'est
le passage en force qui pour des raisons
sécuritaires quand un défenseur est
arrêté ça peut être un peu plus
dangereux donc ça c'est une donnée
supplémentaire qui sécurise l'ensemble
du jeu de rugby
recherchez les espaces s'en allait
obligatoirement au contact
l'enseignement donné par les éducateurs
à versailles tout en préparant aux
plaquages les petits rugbymen dès le
plus jeune âge avec cette volonté
d'éviter les chocs violents
ce jeu de mouvement ça a un intérêt dans
ce sens sur le porteur de balle va
chercher à éviter les défenseurs à
avancer dans les intervalles et donc à
ne pas rentrer dans les murs comme on
peut voir sur certaines vidéos de pro on
apprend sur le plaquage par exemple a
bien passé sa tête sur le côté avec la
tête calée sur la fesse qui est molle
pour ne pas justement se faire mal donc
en fait on apprend plusieurs mouvements
qui nous met en sécurité les enfants à
versailles et les moins de 8 ans joue à
l'épervier adapté au rugby le but ne pas
se faire attraper en traversant le
terrain c'est quand même un jeu
quelconque effet pour le contournement
donc c'est assez intéressant dans le
sens où nous nous ce qu'on recherche
c'est à éviter l'adversaire alors après
il ya ce qu'il y à cette notion
plaquages mais qui est quand même
importante dans le rugby parce qu'on
fait quand même un sport qui en a besoin
un sport qui attire toujours autant les
petits versailles et l'école de rugby
compte près de 250 licenciés chaque
saison sur ces dernières années
rien